Okay, how did you do? Spectacularly well, I hope. let's
go over the solution. Okay, so my solution looks something
like this. First we have an ordered list at the
top and bottom. You know? Opening and closing. And then
we have a for loop for going over the range from 1 to n plus 1 and then we say,
basically, if x is divisible, and we can use the
mod operator to determine if something is divisible. Mod basically
says, it gives you, it gives you the remember. So, x
is divided by 15, what is the remainder. If that, If
that's zero that means x is divisible by both 3 and
5 we print FizzBuzz. If it's divisible by 3 we print Fizz,
if it's divisible by 5 we print Buzz, else we just
print x. And we have our end if and our end for.
Okay, not too bad huh? Now there's lots of ways of,
you know, if you want to minimize the logic done here but
that's not really what I'm trying to look for right here. I
just want to see if you can actually use your for statements
and your if statements and your
variable substitution. And your variable substitution
to make a quick little template. So if you got that, nicely done.